este es uno de los 50 hospitales a lo
largo y ancho de los cuatro países del
reino unido en los que desde esta mañana
muy temprano será administrada esta
vacuna especialmente a la población
sobre los 80 90 años que hace parte dice
el gobierno de la más vulnerable se
espera que esta población esté vacunada
sobre la primavera en 2021 ha sido muy
emotivo el día de hoy 'no lágrimas de
parte del ministro de salud quien vio la
vacunación de la primera persona de la
primera abuelita como tú recordaba en
vivo en televisión así que ha sido un
día muy emotivo pero el primer ministro
también ha llamado a qué bueno es un día
histórico se está avanzando pero no hay
que bajar la guardia la logística como
lo mencionas es bien compleja porque hay
nueve etapas no se sabe cuando la
totalidad de la población y reunido será
vacunada contra el joven por ello dice
el gobierno hay que mantener la
prudencia también la logística es muy
difícil por el transporte de la vacuna
está siendo elaborada en bética pero
debe ser refrigerada al menos 70 grados
de temperatura y por eso hasta está
sólo puede ser administrada en
hospitales como esos que tienen por
supuesto un lugar especial para poder
contar